i would say to anybody you know go for
what you
feel truthfully in your life and you
will be rewarded a million-fold and
heish has died
she's survived by her two sons atlas and
homer i'm so lucky i do i walk around
with a joyous experience i have two
beautiful children
and got her start on the soap opera
another world
leaving today
it's the hardest work anybody could ever
do i say it's the best work you can do
she later transitioned to the big screen
i also like acting in all different
kinds of things you turn them around you
know you turned them around like a well
they just hadn't thought it through
please be careful that doesn't hold you
we fall through it's a great big stunt
where you actually fall into it
there's got to be something speeding
this when it hits a block it's going to
punch through i'm doing
a satire i hope i'm good in that if i'm
doing a romantic comedy i hope i'm good
in that there's this saying let go and
let god
and that's kind of
how i live my life
in 1998 anne starred opposite of
harrison ford and the romantic comedy
six days seven nights well are you gonna
fix it
i mean can't we can't we reattach it
somehow oh sure we'll like
glue it back on we became really good
friends on that movie which is i think
why people like it because they just see
our friendship in it
you still look good
i still am good he gave me the
opportunity to even have a career that
that still stands today honestly because
of the foundation that he gave me by
doing that movie and never stopped
working over the years think of me as an
untapped resource i like life that's
what it is
in 2020 anne hit the ballroom on dancing
with the stars
in between rehearsals she took a moment
to reflect on her past relationship with
ellen degeneres
as ann recalled it was a groundbreaking
moment for hollywood but the spotlight
wasn't always kind to her career
my movie premiere volcano i had told
them that i was taking yellen as my date
and i was told if i took helen i would
lose my fox contract
[Music]
i thought it was a beautiful time to be
able to talk about what had happened 20
years ago and i think we're at a time in
our history where we're able to look
back and say oh now i'm ready for a
little bit a fuller picture of the story
of what happened in my life and and um
the fact that we've run dancing with the
stars made it just make all the more
sense to be able to come out
and uh wear a star-spangled banner for
gay rights really is what i did with my
inside out dress and every single one of
the crew and
and cast really were behind it and
celebrating it and were so
thoughtful and supportive of of knowing
the truth and in me being able to speak
it in such a such a clear and
celebratory way